the Western Cape Southern Peninsula is
blanketed in Smoke as three major fires
burn the largest started on Tuesday more
than 300 firefighters and several
aircraft including drones for
surveillance have been deployed on
Thursday night strong winds caused the
blaze to spread from simonstown into
neighboring scabber and another fire
broke out along the main Highway we uh
jointy manag the fire between ourselves
City of Cape Town fire and rescue uh
with assistance from itial disaster
management um so it is a coordinated
effort um at any given time um we we've
we've had up to 250 uh firefighters on
the fire line um with multiple tankers
um and at times have also used up to six
helicopters uh with spotter planes to
actually bomb some of the fire lines uh
especially yesterday um when when we had
such devastating
winds evacuation orders were issued for
about 100 households many in the early
hours of the morning City authorities
say it's a precautionary
measure on Friday there was some respite
from the wind but there are concerns it
will pick up again Fanning the Flames we
saw the Red Hill informal settlement
which uh through some Act of God was
spared completely from from the damage
um and uh we saw areas uh above Misty
Cliffs where the fire is still
burning
resources are stretched the military has
sent in additional helicopters City
authorities say the situation is
unpredictable and more people may need
to leave their homes while they work to
contain the fires and prevent damage to
properties famida Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer